what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a video donovan sharp
made reacting to me
reacting to him um before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos okay
the white guy finds out that if any
white guy anyway
no that's not true i don't know i've
always just like this is funny this is
my first black like boyfriend but i've
always that's always just been my type
okay listen i'm sure that black guys are
your type and if black guys are her type
that's a w for her
but if any white guy finds out that if
any white guy finds out that a black guy
is her type
that's a wrap okay second gear do you
care if like she's dated black guys
before
oh i get it it was i was confused
because i was like that was pretty late
in the video
okay we're back
plug his book okay
it's a z you can send me a um
video requests on there this is going to
be fun we're taking a little bit of a
detour here but i like it so if anyone
has any videos that they'd want to send
me send it to me on instagram all right
don't care
what
what the
all right donovan that was rude
my instagram i'll have you know my
instagram posts are fire
fire okay
oh she's watching a face of proper among
oh
this is a pre-requisite as a pervasive
proverb among caucasian females when
referring to dating or hooking up with
african-american men and that saying is
once you go black you don't go back what
this means is that once a woman has a
little fun with a black dude she won't
be interested in going back to dating
white guys or any other race of male on
account of the wild and crazy time she
had with the brother now i'm not a white
girl so i can't speak to whether or not
this is true however how could you say i
can't speak to whether or not this is
true
if you're you're literally saying
in the video that this is true
hold on i actually need to move myself
over this way because
i think it would go better for this
video okay
i have a proverb to pick it back off of
that one which rings 256
true and my proverb is once you go black
you can't go back allow me to explain
right
women are extreme
hang on a second i'm told i need to turn
this down a little bit creamily
influenced by perceived social pressure
whether they admit it or not oh my gosh
my lighting is always bad but it's like
exceptionally worse in this video all of
their decisions from what they wear to
where they work to the cars they drive
in their minds are heavily scrutinized
by just about everyone they know
of course this isn't really the case
sure a friend of hers might comment on
her new shoes or the fact that she needs
to find a new job or that her boyfriend
is a loser this is funny she said what
that 45 second conversation her friend
isn't thinking what is
i hate you know okay you know some
people have a natural like resting [ __ ]
face
i have a natural like i'm in shock slash
confused face
down i'm just watching the video
it's not her anymore in fact thinking
about herself the problem is women don't
realize this they're under the
impression that everyone around them men
and women alike are constantly
everything
it's not that i don't believe it i don't
think it's true i'm talking about what
you're talking about
when it comes to like women always
worrying about what other people oh my
god not think that i'm sure a lot of
girls do but
it's hard because in the manner sphere
they'll always tell me that i don't
actually like i say that
but like women
say things that they don't mean but
genuinely uh whenever i get embarrassed
about something that's what i tell
myself is that i probably won't even
remember that's half that's how i do
this channel honestly is mentally i say
that if the video is that bad people
won't watch it all the time as though
they have nothing else to do other than
to watch and talk about her all day
every day this speaks to the extreme
solipsism of the female species more
importantly the reason that when they
mess with black guys a lot of them feel
like they can't date white guys anymore
in her mind if she's seen with a brother
she knows she's probably off limits to
white guys
so now the question becomes
i don't get it why are white then
she doesn't she might not get it because
she might not date white guys girls
consider to be off limits to white guys
once she messes i mean i have like
i just haven't had an experience where
they really care the black guys why do
white guys lose their freaking minds
when they okay dev
deb we gotta reach out to this girl we
gotta reach out to this chick i think
this would be a great conversation i
think this would be a fantastic
fantastic conversation dev get a hold of
this chick get a hold of this chick i i
emailed
her haven't heard anything about a date
yet but who knows i'm patient
my time will come we gotta have her on
the show find out they're pretty
blond-haired blue-white snowflake hey
i'm a ginger thank you been violated by
a brother well the answers are actually
quite simple but before i get to that
why am i here to be off limits i ask
myself that often sometimes when i'm
like in the manosphere content i'm like
what
what am i doing here like why am i here
i like guys if they're messing with
black guys i answered part of this
question in a video i did a while back
discussing the racial implications of
the very first black bachelor in that
franchise's history take a look the
second uncomfortable truth about the
bachelor people are afraid to talk about
out loud is that the white women who
compete will be considered tainted by
white men
yes this is also a thing
what a white man finds out i'm just
gonna
kind of pause from the video
okay that's my thumbnail for a different
okay
um katie thurston
cast
let's see
so
i'm just showing you guys all of the
guys that competed for this girl that
was on matt james this season
um
because he was trying to say this is
like a one-off i just don't see it as
that big of a deal anymore like i'm sure
guys don't prefer it
but
i don't know i don't think guys would
really care
um so anyways this was this guy told
katie
the lead
who is on matt james this season
um that he loved her
this guy proposed to her
this guy loved her
this guy left for his son but look it's
not like it's an all-black cast like
these guys are all pretty white
so you can see
i mean it's like a mix right but
i just i don't know i don't see it being
that big of a deal and then the other
thing
is on the bachelor in paradise which is
like a spin-off
um
mari and kenny
i'll show you another this is another
girl that was on
the bachelorette season so this guy
had a choice um on the left
between three girls that were literally
competing for him so this girl was
competing for him this girl was
competing for him
and there's another girl that they're
not showing here but she also was
competing for him
and he picked the girl that was on matt
james this season
which was her
so i don't know
i'm not saying it's like not a thing it
probably is to some exp extent
but sometimes the manosphere gets like
so wrapped in their little bubble i
think like they forget the rest of the
world isn't like
in this space without his white wife i
think she honestly doesn't know i think
she listened i think she honestly
doesn't know and again dalton turner
says i'm white but yeah i agree with ds
yeah
yes i mean that doesn't make white guys
bad i mean that's just how it is if a
girlfriend had
biblical relations with a black man he
loses his mind she's ruined he thinks
but his adverse reaction is not because
of racism
at least not she's like what most of the
time
it's about the adult film industry and
the media for the most part let me
explain
every black male adult film actor
without exception has an exceptionally
large penis
now the same could be said about the
white counterpart she's killing me she
has no idea this is great shawn oh says
she's naive to this new information i
think this is genuine i think she is
definitely
i think she honestly doesn't know this
is funny how does he know this is there
like a survey or something which is why
they're in the business okay no no okay
the reason stop laughing stop laughing
the reason that i said is there a survey
is because the man of spear is so like
data driven they're like oh women we did
they don't believe the facts
i'm like where can i have your data
because it's just interesting because a
lot of times if like they see anything
that's like
counter to what they believe
then they don't believe it often in the
manosphere it's like a weird echo
chamber sometimes
um
but wait the other one i was going to
show you brie
and
what's his name oh joe
from bachelor
in paradise so these two also get
engaged i forgot one more serena wasn't
serena's mixed
and joe's white and she was also on matt
james's season
um
and then the other one
oh actually no that girl was black so i
think he wouldn't count her
okay
oh my god she really doesn't know
holy [ __ ] she has no idea oh my god
please but the black male actors have
these gargantuan penises that make even
the most impressive looking white
bananas look comparatively small
if any man black or white consumes
enough adult film entertainment with
black actors he's going to internalize
this as the norm i'm just watching her
face because i listen i think this is
genuine i think she really doesn't know
and subconsciously assume that every
black man has a huge penis
add that to the fact that white men are
routinely portrayed in movies and
television as latent or inferior beta
males while black men are portrayed as
these static alphas i can see why some
white guys might hit the eject button if
he finds out his pretty little
fair-skinned companion has been to the
dark side
he's thinking of her being ravaged by
this hulking muscular super alpha with
an eggplant emoji the size of a baseball
bat
this is exactly why a lot of white men
will not date white women who have dated
black men
very few would admit that out loud but a
lot of them really do feel this way
so when white men watch matt james
swapping spit with pretty white women
i felt so uncomfortable during the porn
part i do not like talking about porn i
don't know
those girls are all but discarded from
their lists don't believe me after
lindsey vonn dated tiger woods
white guys stayed away look look at her
face like dude she's blown away by this
i'm gonna be honest i think i was
watching
i think i was on my phone like sometimes
guys
when i'm watching videos and i get bored
or they've been going on for a while i
put my phone like kind of red under the
camera
sorry it's just funny how people
interpret your emotions on the outside
oh my gosh like dude she is shocked she
is really shocked
i was on twitter
i was on twitter only black men would
date her exclusively and now she's
engaged to nhl star pk subon
yeah but how do you know that wasn't
just her type
huh well yes well of course yes that is
her type
lindsay vaughn
listen lindsay vaughn's type now is
black guys right
but that doesn't mean that she's not
still considered to be quote tainted by
white guys who is black
then i guess i guess i'm marrying a
black guy
uh this is funny she doesn't know it but
she is she's gonna have to amber wrote
because i'm gonna tell you what any
white guy she dates if they find out
that she dated a black guy it is not man
i'm trying to tell you it's not going to
be good
it's not going to be good you know what
man i'ma tell you what i'm about to put
her up on game
i'ma have to put her up on game like
real talk
put me up on game what
what does that even mean
really put her up on game because she
really doesn't know
you think white guys are lining up to
date i'll be i'll be the experiment well
amber rose
isn't she half black her giving her it
doesn't matter sweet cheeks
doesn't matter she's considered to be a
white girl hating history i think
there's a lot of reasons people consider
amber rose tainted
i'm i'm gonna just be honest
i don't make the rules but facts are
facts and at the end of the day every
white contestant on matt james's season
of the bachelor will find it very
difficult to find white men who will
date or marry them
wait
you know what i was just thinking
there's another contestant um that's in
a relationship now
um
what was her name oh abigail
and
noah i think his name was
i gotta put the badge blur
yeah so then this guy i don't think
they're i think they're just dating i
don't they the season hasn't finished
yet but i don't think he proposes at the
end because you have like
the option to propose or like leave
together
but
oh and this is another one
like i can't even
this is how i know it's not as prevalent
really
anymore i mean i'm sure like when
segregation and stuff was really
like a different time
um okay
and then this is the other couple
that they're dating now i think they
left together but
so because his conclusion was that all
the girls on the show
would have a hard time getting white
guys to like date them or marry them
and i'm i can't find
a girl dating a black guy like they're
all dating white guys from the show
that's a difficult truth to acknowledge
for these that's what i'm saying like if
girls are fit feminine friendly enough
like
i mean i don't think guys prefer it but
i don't think most guys will care the
one thing about the manosphere is guys
will cap so hard
about what they will and won't date like
they'll have all these requirements and
like
say they won't date this this this this
and this but most guys if they find a
girl they like they don't care these
girls but it is indeed the truth today
is white men i mean just like him right
and the man was for they they preach
dating younger women right like under 30
but he started dating his girlfriend at
38.
because he found a girl he liked and
that's fine like
i won't knock him for it
but
i feel like i probably agree with him to
some extent
but i think it's more like
guys don't want a girl that's like
has a high body count you know distantly
show and tell white women that once
they're marked as a wet and dirty shark
which is a derogatory label assigned to
white girls who date black guys she is
then considered to be undateable mudjark
and unmarriable now white men would
never admit this out loud or the group
but black men are a threat to them in
terms of dating market value
yes white guys are at the top of the
dating market food chain meaning that
all things being equal most white girls
prefer white men but conventional wisdom
in their circles is that man for men
black men are physically superior have
more game and are much better between
the sheets than they are whether or not
this is actually true doesn't seem to
matter but the fact of the matter is
that mainstream media portrays black
males as static alphas who generate
tingles with every interaction they have
with a woman then like i previously
discussed when you factor in interracial
adult films into the mix where every
black male actor has an enormous sausage
which of course further perpetuates the
bbc myth
and no i'm not talking about the british
broadcasting channel no wonder white
dudes stay away from white girls who
have come to the dark side even one time
in their lives
so rather than admitting the truth about
their dating market options white girls
use the word don't in place of the word
can't they do this to give themselves
and the world the impression that they
know
no that's not true i don't know i've
always just like this is funny this is
my first black like boyfriend but i've
always that's always just been my type
okay listen i'm sure that black guys are
your type and if black guys are her type
that's a w for her
but if any white guy finds out that if
any white guy finds out that a black guy
is her type
that's a wrap
i mean okay here's the thing i don't
have a dog in this fight like i'm gonna
be honest i don't
care
if people on the internet like
say they wouldn't date me or like i kind
of put it like
um
like i don't know i don't really care
um
so i tried to think of what he's doing
he's not like saying he wouldn't date me
but i don't know if he thinks that
that's fine and there's probably some
truth to it i just think in the
manosphere like
it's just such an echo chamber that i
think we forget like the rest of the
world isn't the manosphere
and like most guys if they find a girl
they like they really don't care they
wouldn't prefer it sure but
you know
everyone always says that until they
find someone they like
that has that quality
look at her and you can see her hold on
let me rewind it a little bit watch her
watch this this is my first this is
funny it's like she
you can if you watch her face she it's
almost like she's like she's in denial
she's like no no wait a minute is it
true
i'm not in denial i'm just processing
like people say things and then i like
it takes me a second to process what you
say i have to think about it like
because this is what i do i when i hear
a theme from the manosphere right i
think does this apply in my real life
and i think back
to what i've seen in in real life
and
my two friends that are getting engaged
like probably the earliest
both of them lost their virginities to
black guys and both of their fiances
know i'm sure they're not like
whoopee i'm so excited but you know they
found a girl they liked
it's fit feminine friendly submissive
enough
you know
it is what it is and the world the
impression that they
know watch watch
look no that's not true i don't know i
don't know all always just like this is
my first black like boyfriend but i've
always that's always just been my type
because this is what i'm doing i'm
thinking back is this what i see in real
life
i'm not like in shock donovan i don't
know
look she's really she's really thinking
about it now go back to dating white
guys if they wanted to no there was a
white guy that wanted to date me i
didn't want to date him
okay but did he know you
did he know that you were a um
like did he
did he yeah i didn't think so
why'd you say didn't you let me answer
the question
no he definitely did like
but no he didn't care
but
no okay
no she's in denial this is funny she's
like no it can't be i think that they
probably couldn't if word got out about
her proclivities to commingle with
brothers here's another question is this
really about race in the first place
in short no let me give you a personal
example if i were interested in a woman
approached her got her number and set up
the date then listen to her swoon over
her ex-boyfriend who stood at six five
three percent body fat who was worth
seven figures and at a 13 inch sausage i
would not set up a second date you want
to know something this race wouldn't
matter whether this mythical man were
asian i would hope you would not talk to
a girl again if she did that on a first
date i would hope to god
white black or hispanic his race would
be of little or no consequence the fact
that i don't measure up statistically to
her ex is what would keep me away not
his race today's white men live that
make-believe scenario every time they
see a good-looking wife look at her face
look at her face
listen i don't think that she
i think that she is in denial about this
but you can tell
you can tell that this is not
preposterous
you can tell girl holding hands with a
black guy no they can't assume uh oh
she's calling her brother
what oh my god dude oh my [ __ ] god
she's gonna call her brother what is net
worth she's gonna text her brother this
but if that guy's in decent shape oh
dude i hope she tells us what he says
white guys automatically assume oh my
god this is it she's like i'm gonna i'm
gonna text my brother i want to see what
he thinks that he is plowing her sensely
i should call i should call my brother's
girlfriend
i should see
i don't know if i want to do this to him
is she gonna answer
let's see
hi this is melissa
yeah
i'm just curious i wonder if she hats i
don't know
with this baseball bat sized male organ
in a white guy's mind look she's doing
it right now that he'll never be able to
smash her or take her on the she's
calling him right now emotional
rollercoaster ride let's see who my
brother says holy [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god
we've stumbled on a [ __ ] gold mine oh
please pick up
the brother i tried my older brother he
didn't answer
he's 27 or maybe 28 years to be doing
for her
if he saw a pretty white girl with a
white guy who was tall i don't think
he's saying good looking and
self-assured he'd probably answer the
phone
[ __ ] have those same assumptions
so this scarlet letter has more to do
with the perceived persona of black men
and less with our skin tone she looks
blown away
and you can tell guys listen you can
tell that she's not sure
you can tell she's not she's like no
this can't be well then why would she
want to call her brother
this is wonderful she's like hold on i
gotta call my brother
i like to give every idea the benefit of
the doubt
i'm sure it's true to some extent i just
don't think it's that big of a deal in
2020. a while back i did a podcast
called why do parents discourage their
teens from interracial
in that episode i stated that if white
father showed their daughters what a
strong
masculine head of household was rather
than allowing themselves to her face oh
my god bossed around and marginalized by
their bossy wives their daughters would
be far less likely to date outside of
their race namely black guys another
element i pointed out was that white
fathers know that if their white
daughters had a reputation for dating
black men or black boys in high school
she would essentially take herself out
of the running to secure a high-value
white male at least in the city or
country they live in my dad literally
does not care oh fathers can see
sweetheart oh he cares they can give
politically correct answers if he cares
public but deep down they know that if
their white daughters date hook up with
mary or even have a baby with a black
hair her dating options would be greatly
limited in that regard
guess what white fathers it's okay to
feel this way this isn't about race it's
about your daughter essentially
rejecting men like you it's the very
same reason that black mothers lose this
is fun i feel like he has not been my
dad
one time i asked my dad to pick out my
husband
and he literally declined
my dad is the most laid back like he
does not care
this is funny as [ __ ] so now she's like
my father literally does not care and
now she's probably texting her dad
i was texting my brothers their minds
now i will say this i will say this in
my opening opening monologue or maybe i
was on twitter
i wouldn't be shocked
right at the end my opening theme is
of course your parents don't of course
uh wait a minute of course your parents
don't care that i'm a black guy you're
past the wall
devon has told me
evie what i'm not passing the wall
oh my god do i do i look like i'm past
the wall
now i'm hurt
oh my gosh
no
no i don't care
donovan i'm 24 i'm almost 25. i will
give you that i turned 25 in like a
month and a half
but i'm 24.
you and i were in a relationship when we
were teenagers my dad would not like i
do not look 35
i
maybe late 20s i do not look 35 get out
of here i mean i'm not offended by that
that's just the way it is
my high school girlfriend my high school
sweetheart jill
her father quote unquote didn't like me
he hated the fact that we were dating
and listen all these years later i'm not
saying what he did was right or wrong
but i understand why
jill's father had a problem with us
dating i had i do not hold that against
him
i do not hold that against him at all
it's when they're black sons look she's
texting her dad this is white women
trying my other brother oh my god she
has two brothers
oh my god i hope
i have like five brothers
oh
sorry oh my god
hold up i gotta turn this up
wait adam
my brother's here adam
i'm gonna see if
oh i think my mom's cooking dinner hold
up
hey mom
hello
yeah
um i need to finish a video it's got
seven minutes left
okay um is it adam down there
can you tell him to come up i need him
i need him for the video ask him if
he'll come up
did he say no
dang okay okay bye
he's busy
i tried i did my best
hold up i gotta turn this up he answered
the phone
dude
yo this is must-see tv
hold up
oh my god this is insane
um kind of not really okay can i ask you
just a quick question
it's like it's a dating question okay
does it intimidate you if you date a
girl and or you're like interested in a
girl and you find out her ex is like
better looking uh makes more money like
basically
she's not asking the right question i
will
i will let me get to it i didn't want to
preface like
i felt like the order i asked him
because first i asked if he's
intimidated by an axe that's better than
you in every way
um
because i didn't want to like
have him answer it differently based on
the other question
she's not asking the right question she
needs to say black guy uh-uh she's not
asking the right question every way then
you
no because guess who's here now
okay second question oh see
no because guess who's here now
okay second here we go do you care if
like she's dated black guys before
no
okay that's it very racist
stop the cow that doesn't mean you're
racist
that does not mean you're racist but see
this is the interesting thing about the
manosphere
when
someone doesn't give the answer that
they they see as truth they hear is
truth
like then all of a sudden that person's
lying
so that's just interesting about the
meadows fear is my dad or my brother who
didn't know anything about the video
other than what i told him
um didn't give the answer that he wanted
so
like then all of a sudden i i see the
comments section where they're like oh
he's not telling the truth it's just an
interesting echo chamber sometimes man
listen look guys um listen this is not
this does not like if you're a white guy
and again
again
dude there are black guys
there are black guys
who wouldn't date white girls if he
found out she dated other black dudes
they're out there dude i knew
man brothers are like listen i date
white girls but if she's dated other
black dudes i'm staying away real talk
real [ __ ] talk dude
and now her brother of course is giving
her
the politically correct wait a minute no
that's racist no it has nothing to do
with being racist oh my gosh you realize
my brother's a conservative like
[Music]
like he's not my brother's bullied me
growing up they do not care that's
nothing to do with being racist
that like white guys won't date a girl
that um
like white guys one dated girl she like
is known for dating black guys so i was
just wondering for you it's a very
racist thing yeah he's not saying no he
says that's racist he literally said no
donovan
but trust me her brother cares like did
you did you that's what's funny like the
manosphere literally hears what they
want to hear
oh my gosh i agree i was just wondering
of course you agree
gregan has a black axe and um
had a black ex-boyfriend too but okay so
i want to clarify the girls that he's
listing so
the first girl that he listed was his
last girlfriend
so
and the next girl that he listed is the
girl that he's dating
now and he's literally so in love with
and obsessed with and it's so cute so
he's saying that the girls that he's
dated have had black exes
but he's lying according to the
manosphere
but actually on the second one
okay okay thanks i'm gonna finish my
video
hell even i can admit that if i had a
daughter i feel some type of way if she
chose to be with a white guy does that
make me a racist no it makes me a human
being the once you go black trope is the
quintessential example of women not
acknowledging the truth about their
status in the dating market if they are
ever labeled as the white girl who dates
black dudes and that truth is that once
she is lit dude look how uncomfortable
she is she knows her brother and dude
she has a black boyfriend
right
she has a black boyfriend of course her
of course of course her brother's not
gonna tell her well no it's not gonna
tell her the truth okay but don't what
do you always say in the manosphere
don't look at what they say watch what
they do
it's just so interesting sometimes
that's like how the manosphere is though
you kidding me
label this such short of moving to
another state and starting anew with new
friends or racing all facebook or other
social media pictures she will be all
but invisible to white men this is why
she's watching the entire video oh my
god i cannot wait to talk to this girl
i do that in all my videos
unless the unless the video is like
if it's over 45 minutes 30 minutes i
might cut it or it's just really
repetitive
like what a 10 15 minute video
i'm just chilling
i would agree with this assertion white
girls can act like they have the option
to go back if they chose to by proudly
proclaiming they won't but i've always
said that women are far more aware of
the truth regarding intersexual dynamics
than men will ever be and it is for this
reason alone that they understand very
clearly that once they go black they
can't go back so white guys am i wrong
about you guys staying away from white
girls if they've messed with black guys
or are you going to admit the truth and
like this is the thing i hate about the
man of spirit like they are the keepers
of truth they know all the answers yes
actually we do
you guys don't think that's a little
arrogant
just just a little bit you can't be
wrong about anything
so it's we do
what extents do you guys go to to cover
up your dark side escapades i'd be very
interested to find out so it's
interesting like watch what they say or
watch what they do in his example
every single girl from that show is
dating
that's dating someone is dating a white
guy or engaged to a white guy
but i don't even know what point i'm
arguing here because i'm sure it's a
thing like i'm sure there's so there's
some truth to everything right
but i just don't think it's i haven't
found that it's that big of a deal and
most people care that much if they're
into the girl and don't forget if you
want sometimes the manners fear is weird
um
if a white if a white dude and a woman
live in the same community and everyone
in their circle knows she has a history
of black there it is dudes that's going
to be that's not going to be any
relationship the whites dudes will
probably smash but that's it if they
live in a large city or move out of town
it won't be as big of a deal but it's
wise for the woman to keep quiet about
that history if she wants a relationship
if she has a mixed kid that guy says
that's it that's it i do think the kid
is a thing like i think guys typically
if they're going to be a stepdad would
prefer a kid that looks like them so
like not everyone walking in the store
has to know that's not their kid
um
in group preferences all over the world
that isn't unique to black white
um
okay well
after watching a few of kevin samuel's
podcast and seeing the woman
who can blame black men yeah he says
after seeing uh uh after watching a few
kevin samuels podcast and seeing i can't
read that comment you know i can't read
that comment that's why i stopped black
women behave who can blame black men for
wanting to date out
the history of saying once you go black
was intended to serve as a warning to
white women who would
befall them and should opt for the
chocolate doing their
ostracized for
from respectable society and all of its
benefits noticed this was never said or
directed or forced when white men got
with black women
right
of course it was of course it it the
same thing does not apply
if a white girl is dating a white guy
and he found out and she found out that
she had dated that and she and he found
out or she found out that he had dated a
black woman that has absolutely
positively no bearing on their
relationship
he is not tainted at all it he doesn't
yeah because men and women are different
we know that like i'm not naive enough
to think
that men and women aren't different but
let me know in the comments how
prevalent do you think it is
do you think the majority of guys would
really stop talking to a girl that he
actually liked if he found out that she
dated a black guy before
but my gut's telling me the majority of
guys
wouldn't
but let me know let me know if you think
i'm wrong
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell and i'll
talk to you guys next time